we already have a lot of experience with
the geometric series for example if I
have the infinite geometric series
starting at N equals K to infinity of R
to the N which would be R to the K plus
R to the K plus 1 plus R to the K plus 2
and keep going on and on and on forever
there's a few things we've already
thought about here we know what the
common ratio is so the common ratio the
common ratio which is the ratio between
consecutive terms is going to be R to
the K plus 1 actually let me just write
this as R to the n plus 1 I don't want
to fixate on this K right over here so R
to the N plus 1 over R to the N well
this is just going to be equal to R
anything to the n plus 1 over that same
thing at the end that's just going to be
equal to R R to the first power and you
see that here when you go from one term
to another you are just multiplying
you're just multiplying by R and this is
all this is all review if it's not
review I encourage you to watch the
videos on geometric series and what's
interesting about this is we've proven
to ourselves in the videos on geometric
series that if if if the common ratio if
the absolute value of the common ratio
is less than 1 then then the series the
series converges converges and if the
absolute value of R is greater than or
equal to 1 then the series diverges and
that made sense we've proven it as well
but it also makes logical sense that
look if if the absolute value of R is
less than 1 then each term here is going
to be is going to go down by that common
or it's going to be multiplied by that
common ratio and it's going to decrease
on and on and on and on and on and so it
makes sense that even though this is an
infinite sum it will converge to a
finite value now with that out of the
way for review let's tackle let's tackle
something a little bit more interesting
let's say that we want to look at a we
want to figure out whether a series like
this so starting with N equals 5 to
infinity
of let's say n to the 10th power the
numerator is growing quickly n to the
10th power
over n factorial n factorial we know
also grows very very quickly probably it
actually grows much faster than then
even then even a high degree polynomial
like this or a high degree term like
this but how do we prove that it
converges we can definitely use the
divergence test to show that this does
not diverge but how do we prove that
this actually converges and maybe we can
use a little bit of our intuition here
well let's see if we can come up with a
common ratio so let's see if there's a
common ratio here so let's take the n
plus 1 term which is going to be n plus
1 to the 10th power over n plus 1
factorial and divide that by the end
term so let's divide that by n to the
10th over n factorial
well dividing by a fracture divided by
anything is equivalent to multiplying by
its reciprocal so let's just multiply by
the reciprocal so times n factorial over
N to the 10th remember all I'm trying to
do is exactly what we did right over
here see if there's some type of a
common ratio well if we do a little
algebra here n plus 1 factorial n
factorial algebra is always fun this is
the same thing as n plus 1 times n
factorial times n factorial you're not
used to seeing order of operations do
them with factorial where the spectral
only applies to this n right over here
and why is that useful because this n
factorial cancels with that n factorial
and we're left with n plus 1 to the 10th
power over n plus 1 times n to the 10th
times n to the 10th so I know what
you're thinking hey wait look this isn't
a fixed common ratio here the ratio
between consecutive terms here when I
took the n plus 1 term divided by the
nth term it's changing depending on what
my n is this ratio I guess you could say
is a function is a function of n so this
doesn't seem too
useful but what if I were to say okay
well look in any of these series we
really care about the behavior as our
ends get really really really real our
jazz we the limit as our ends go to
infinity so what if we were to look at
the behavior here and if this is
approaching some actual values and
approaches infinity well it would make
conceptual sense that we could kind of
think of that as our what the common the
limit of our common ratio so let's do
that so let's take the limit as n
approaches infinity of this thing so
remember what we're doing here this
isn't just kind of some voodoo
conceptually so let me copy and paste
this conceptually we're just trying to
think about well what is the common
ratio approach what is the ratio between
consecutive terms the n plus 1 term in
the nth term as n gets really really
really really really large and what you
see here is we have this up here we
don't have to multiply it out this is
going to be n to the 10th plus a bunch
of other stuff it's going to be a 10th
degree polynomial and this down here
this is going to be actually this one we
can figure it out this is going to be n
to the xi plus n to the 10th power so
the limit as n approaches infinity well
this denominator is going to grow faster
than that you could divide the numerator
and denominator by n to the 10th and all
of and and everything well you could
divide actually the numerator
denominator by n to the 11th and
everything up here is going to go to 0
and this is going to be 1 and so the
limit right over here is the limit this
limit is going to be equal to this limit
is going to be equal to 0 as n
approaches infinity one way the ratio
between the ratio between consecutive
terms approaches zero so this seems if
you if we use the the the logic from our
common ratio up here when we looked at
geometric series this is clearly not a
geometric series but it would say well
look as n gets really really really
large the ratio between consecutive
terms gets smaller and smaller and
smaller hey maybe we can make the same
conclusion maybe we can make the same
conclusion that therefore the series the
series actually converges the series
actually converges
so or n factorial converges so can we
make this statement and the answer is
yes we can and what allows us to do it
is the ratio test is the ratio test let
me write that down the ratio test and
all the ratio test tells us is if we
have an infinite series if we have an
infinite series and I can say from N
equals K to infinity and if we say if we
take the limit as n approaches infinity
as n approaches infinity of the absolute
value of a to the n plus 1 over a to the
N and over here I didn't take the
absolute value of that limit but we
absolutely could have taken the absolute
value of that limit and these were all
of these terms right over here were
positive so the absolute value would be
the same thing as itself if this
approaches some limit if this approaches
some limit so once again this limit is
what is going to be our R ratio between
consecutive terms as n gets larger and
larger the ratio tells us if if L is
less than 1 which was the situation here
L is clearly less than 1 then the series
converges series converges some
definitions you say they'll it's
absolutely convergent will convert
absolutely the absolute value of the
series converges but then that also
means that the series itself converges
if L is greater than 1 series diverges
series diverges and if L is equal to 1
its inconclusive we don't know we don't
know we would have to do some other test
to prove whether it converges or
diverges so that's the essence of the
ratio test find the absolute value of
the ratio between consecutive terms take
the limit as n approaches infinity if
that approaches a actual limit and that
limit is less than 1 then the series
converges and it's really based on the
same fundamental idea
that we saw with the common ratio of
geometric series